and now it's time for bombing reviews
with Chester a bum
tonight's review the clavicles have
known there's these kids and they're at
a train station and the train station
turns into a Fantasyland train stations
who do that I another train station that
turned into a Fantasyland of course I
was smoking something probably it was in
The Wizard of Oz except with bloodshed
and there's this mousie he's so cute and
he sounds just like that stand-up
comedian what's his name um Carlos
Mencia wait no that's not it Eddie
Izzard he sounds like Eddie Izzard who's
kind of like Carlos Mencia except that
he's British he likes to wear dresses
and he's funny and the name of the lion
is a slant they named him after a world
populated by asses what kind of a name
is that anyway it's like calling a
giraffe but Kingdom it makes no sense
and there's towards they can't wars in
it and their names are grumpy grumpy and
grumpy if they weren't very happy
towards so anyway the kids come back
it looks like Narnia has been taken over
by the Italians they're like we have
descriptive notes because we want to
make a pizza pie they all kind of look
like Mario and the devil Mario and the
devil if it should be musica Mario and
the devil he's an Italian plumber he's
the Lord of all darkness Mario and the
devil copyright Chester a pump so the
kids are like we have to stop the
Italians so they take out their weapons
in the first movie does he do birthday
parties I would like a giant watery man
at my birthday party if I could remember
when it was I pretty sure it was the day
I was born
isn't that when most birthdays are and
Andy and the kids are like we have to go
back and one kid is like why they're
kids like because and they're like are
we ever coming back
no we're never coming back and I'm like
bullcrap you've got like six more books
man you're coming back it's like Harry
Potter you'll never die I think that
should be the name of the next movie The
Chronicles of Narnia they'll never die
they'll just run out of money so it was
good very good good enough to see twice
please send me money so I can see it
twice I swear I won't refuse it on booze
I had also used it on drugs this is just
a reef bomb saying change you can't
change fuck about our guy are we good
bye Jane
hey that Obama guy wanted change and I
bet you gave him Anika